so a McCallum arson
real science at University of Edinburgh
miletto and the Royal societies and
other why philosophy science mothers to
science
now the philosophy of science should
matter the science is not a foregone
conclusion and philosophy of science has
often been the target of bad press among
scientists dismissive claims in my view
originate from widespread and the
misguided assumption namely that
philosophy of science has to be of use
to scientists otherwise it's no use at
all in reply I would like to say that
philosophy of science like any other
fields in humanities is valuable and
it's valuable to ask why humankind's
they have a very sophisticated
scientific history and cultural heritage
we build narratives about science we
like to scrutinize modeling practices
and methodology in science because it's
it's part of our knowledge it's of our
tradition and moreover philosophy
science plays an important social
function and media coverage and public
discourse on science is often
intertwined with controversies stirred
by political lobbyists and it is the job
of scientists in those cases to find the
evidence and the scientific facts but
it's equally the job of philosophers of
science to work alongside scientists and
to stand up for science and build the
narratives about issues such as evidence
and the natural natural progress and
truth and realism and pluralism in
science because those narratives
ultimately mother the mother to us
and the mother to political
decision-making and the public policy